hakima kokaté ministre conseiller de la
présidence centrafricaine
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france on a entendu un
opposant anicet dologuélé dire que
beaucoup de centres africains ne sont
pas allés voter aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est conforme à la réalité
qu'en savez-vous combien d'ailleurs de
bureaux de vote sont restés fermés
aujourd'hui madame je vous remercie de
m'avoir donné la parole et qui est sûr
c'est que les chais à 18 heures les
délégués ne vous a pas dit la vérité
laisser-aller des marges dans le billet
destin de leur car qui a un parti
politique où il ya eu beaucoup des
membres de son parti qui ont quitté son
parti de cela un an et dix ans un
particulier le plus rien du tout aimé je
dors il réalise et espérait beaucoup
plus par rapport aux consignes de vote
de monsieur vous posez au rwanda pour
avoir le soutien des militants des
quinquas affectueux compétir avec le
président russe s'est arrangé touadéra
alors ce que nous léguer le ne sait pas
c'est que lurel du week-end été roulés
dans la farine par le chef françois
pauzé des rétines aussi un accord à
bosingwa
après cet accord de le guérir ans s'est
noyé a bondi à 10 ans qu'il a organisé
un concours et malheureusement ce
concours est retournée contre monsieur à
l'intérieur j'ai de righini bout des
accords dans la farine ou simplement
vous devez a demandé à fait à côté ce
n'est pas sale ou posant un lycéen de
langues il est juste quelle est la
situation au niveau du vote
quels sont votre quel est votre constat
ce soir même ce soit je peux vous dire
que les centrafricains ont massivement
le ffm déplacement dans le bureau de
vote dans des zones où nenê force et
irrégulières représenté par baudrier
empêcher les trafics et pour ne pas
aller voter
ils ont manifesté leur volonté d'aller
faire remplir devoir citoyen et est pour
ça que la communauté internationale et
les trafics et dans la majorité ils ont
constaté que ces autres vous tous les
centrafricains ont décidé de cette nuit
était la vérité des urnes qui quelques
heures
françois bozizé à l'ex chef de l'état
renversé en 2013 on le rappelle a
exprimé son soutien à la rébellion il a
appelé les centrafricains à ne pas aller
voter ou est ce qu'ils se trouvent
françois bozizé et quel est le sort qui
lui est réservé est ce que vous leur
chercher ce que les forces de sécurité à
centrafricaine le recherchent
aujourd'hui nous surprend sa volée
régulière a rompu le dialogue avec les
autorités
monsieur françois bozizé lui-même a dit
crémant qui soutient la rébellion est
monsieur de 74 en plus je ne sais pas si
ça sera qu'un pas maintenant qu'ils
continuent de soutenir la rébellion
je me pose la question de savoir si ces
messieurs correct monsieur françois
bozizé ne sera pas suivi danser les
aventures où le centre ainsi que ne veut
plus en entendre parler
alors il soutient fermement d'être à la
tête de la cpc mais madame je ne vous
dis une chose quelque chose d'assez
piscine pour des personnes éclairées des
personnes intelligentes qui ont le sens
de comprendre les choses
la cpc nous notre explication ces autres
la cpc ferry coïncidence vous que vous
voulez
hervé à françois bozizé parce que
visiblement vu cette déclaration ils
constituent un problème dans le cadre de
cette élection
il est aussi sous le coup de poursuites
judiciaires on le sait donc il était
rentré au pays à la fin de deux il ya
très peu de temps donc quel est le sort
qu'ont que vous lui réservez le suspense
à bout de lui même il connaît son sort
il a été chef de l'état pendant dix ans
et je pensais que si c'était à linverse
et se brise et allait se comporter
autrement alors son sort est clair le
sort de cette race à vous irez entre les
mains de la justice nationale et
internationale
donc au jour d'aujourd'hui il n'y aura
aucune aucune négociation et aucun
dialogue avec les chiffres ça bozizé qui
avait amené dans notre pays
des mercenaires et lectoure où tu es le
trafic elle et il veut encore ainsi
pillé en 2020 non au lieu au ballon est
ce qu'il ya des soutiens extérieurs à
françois bozizé je vais vous dire une
chose mais ce françois bozizé c'est
parce que il ya un concombre passé vous
avez à ces groupes armés qu'il a le
soutien de la france
malheureusement force est de constater
que la france n'est plus jamais
s'aligner dernière cette aventure est ce
monsieur qui a eu à occuper de hautes
fonctions au niveau de l'état et qui va
mentir aux mains des grands pays comme
la france
alors que la france ne se reconnaît pas
dans ses aventures à lui et du moment où
il n'y a pas longtemps le chef de l'état
le président faustin archange touadéra
avec le président mac ans les autorités
françaises voulez qu'on vous le concerné
elle ne soutiennent pas françois bozizé
pour nous
les autorités françaises ne soutiennent
pas favorisés parce qu'il ya eu un dash
l échange très fructueux entre le
président marc corps
les présidentes madeira donc aux usa a
menti il avait le soutien de la france
juste cette dernière question qui
concerne la ceeac la communauté
économique des états d'afrique centrale
qui a annoncé envisager l'envoi de
troupes en sont les les discussions
là-dessus qui qui peut envoyer des
troupes aujourd'hui en centrafrique pour
était justement votre pouvoir
une raison ça c'est une question qui il
est question qui relève beaucoup plus de
la sécurité une quelque chose qui que je
ne peux pas vous le dire que les
antennes parce que s'engageaient
centrafricaine et les pays de la serre
c'est avec un secret défense est il donc
pas d'accord merci beaucoup à vous à
jacky mas kokaté je rappelle que vous
êtes ministre conseiller de la
présidence centrafricaine merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct